hell yeah guys you're next coming oh my
god he was so proficient today that in
between the start of this show signing
up and now we got a haircut so please
guys get up for Hans camp thank you guys
let me not waste any of your time it's
not my style they're so efficient with
time it's crazy we're just gonna we're
just gonna pack in the last for this set
not a wasted moment all killer no filler
so datings weird I was walking up an
escalator and the students like to what
people walk of escalators that's make
any sense because but then I didn't hear
the rest of that sentence because I was
covering so much [ __ ] distance
[Laughter]
lucked into the dust man got to my
destination you think people would play
Bluetooth speaker music a lot of love
like never crossed paths with each other
you think they've ever felt like man
that's annoying wait a minute if I know
I saw a sign in my neighborhood it said
20 miles per hour when children are not
present
but what if the children are dwelling in
the past I still woman was really into
yoga and choke sex so you enjoy
breathing or not make up your mind you
Valenti oh good I think women are right
beautiful I get in trouble for this
stare at them a lot because to be a
woman is like a beautiful scenic sunset
that can yell at you they're like a
mountainside that has a boyfriend
a beach with pepper spray so you can't
take a picture even they come on - I'm
single pretty long way I don't think I
could ever have sex again because 99% of
my sex career was so low now I have time
in Oregon the muscle was breathing on me
I know my name is good my glasses all
foggy my dick sticky you got my dick
stick what smells chair I'm gonna [ __ ] I
love the ladies I don't think I'm gonna
have sex with a dude sorry fellas that's
bigger and hairier and that's less
kindness I'll put that on my butthole
straightest Club
[Applause]
I think capitalism is fine if you want
to do it just don't make everyone
playing stupid game I like fortnight I
don't make your grandma play take
warehouse abuses
I like how Americans will say communism
never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars to kill billions of
people to make sure it went to work
remember the war in Vietnam
Panama whew we're pretty anxious about
it not working cousin never works
because whatever people can roll them
into production the Democratic Lee like
the leaders this seriously died and the
smaller boys finds automatic weapons
themselves
[Applause]